so in this video i'll be talking about
how to manage being a student and doing
only fans as you probably might not know
i am a mechanical engineering student at
an ivy league university obviously
oh man
you look like one of them ninjas from
you were one of the ninjas from ninja
turtles
the enemy ninjas who fight with shredder
shredder
uh
she looked like shredder in this [ __ ]
talk about how do i manage being a
student having only fans no how do you
manage having a hijab and doing what we
face that's what we really want to know
i don't even know if i should cover this
path
yeah cause you're exposing a
[ __ ]
you cover face
just
cover her face more than she's covered
what i clicked on her profile and she
showed her face it's funny because the
haram and you just went oh [ __ ] you
can't do that hi everyone welcome back
to my youtube channel my name is maryam
hadid and i am an engineering student at
a top ivy league university in the u.s
that was not necessary
and this girl she went from before
hey job
to now having
like her shirt like zipped down the
titties starting to pop out and look i
don't really care what you do but i'm
reconsidering how i start this video now
because i feel like it was a marketing
ploy yeah
yes yeah there's no way you come from a
family like this and think you're gonna
live like this no and nobody's gonna see
what you're doing no no something that
you might or might not know about me is
that i do porn
and i actually started to help my family
that lost their money due to the
economic crisis in lebanon my plan in
the future is to of course continue
helping my family but also build my own
engineering firm just a fun fact
engineers only make around sixty
thousand to a hundred thousand dollars
per year
and i make around this much in just one
month
yeah uh that's when they're alive
she makes that in a month yeah sixty
she is definitely doing a lot of hiv
play oh yeah there's dudes who will pay
lots
i know because i'm one of those dudes i
mean if you guys could see my search
history on point
yeah that most death
oh
that's how mia khalifa got got got known
yeah she was doing a lot of the videos
okay man listen she's been doing this
for a lot long
bro that's so weird that's so weird for
how long
i don't really have insightful
commentary it's just the thought of like
a hydraulic girl just probably saying i
do i do prawn
it's crazy
it's crazy the fact that she says it
what she's doing is haram but what
you're doing is haram too
the way that you haven't been taking
care of your skin we're going to stop
that today with our sponsor tash henley
take it away preach t.h henley what i
would suggest you to do
i suggest you to take and to start with
the level one system it's a box what
kind of products they got in the box i'm
about to tell you right now well first
of all they have a face wash you don't
want to get all in the nooks and
crannies all the pores get all the grime
out boom they have a moisturizer as an
spf uh 20 in there you know to have a
little protection from the sun they have
instruction with the products that
you're gonna use to tell you when to use
the products how to use the products go
on the link below right now click on the
link below and save 30 off your first
purchase and also you can get a free
gift from t.h henley i'm just saying if
you wash your booty
wash your beauty
that was genius hi mariam hadid here and
it's just another weekend for me so i
thought i would make another youtube
video
in this video i'll be talking about how
i make 18 000 a month and i'm only 18
years old so if there's anything that i
have learned over the past couple of
months is that no matter what you do
people will always criticize you and
they'll always find something
to criticize you about so i've just
learned not to listen to these people
and just do whatever it takes for
me to be satisfied with myself and end
up paying my bills and whatever else i
need to do there's always one rule that
i keep in mind is that i can do whatever
i need to make my ends meet
what
how
how what
just don't wear the hijab i mean you
could do whatever the hell you want
that's none of my business why i left
islam and she's still wearing the hijab
exactly
exactly something it doesn't mean it's
it's a it's a it's a
yeah
it's not possible it makes no sense this
is a marketing point it's a marketing
thing and i can understand why people
would get upset because like i could
imagine if you over here holding a cross
and having dudes jerk off on it there's
probably a lot of christians out there
who would feel some type of way right
these religious symbols mean things to
certain people and so when they see you
bastardizing it i can understand why
they feel some type of way the same way
if you go to an american and you start
burning the flag they're going to feel
some type of way it doesn't justify like
the violence that comes afterwards and
all that stuff i'm not saying that but
no doubt if you were burning the flag
and pissing on it people would feel some
type of way take a military symbol yep
take a military uniform and start peeing
on it yeah how do you think people gonna
feel
not good understandably so yeah
absolutely so even though i'm not
religious in that sense i also know not
to just like go out of my way to
disrespect things that mean things to a
lot of people right i just saw that and
i just really wondered like it it really
doesn't say something wrong it's a
marketing like it doesn't go to why like
just don't wear your hijab then because
because of all the whole meaning of what
a hijab is and you do
extreme opposite hey hey man listen i'm
just saying
i don't know if there's an isis hit list
out there somewhere but if there is
your name's probably gonna be on it this
is crazy this is wild that's crazy
that's wow
here let's find out why she left islam
this is the story of why i left islam
part one i was born and raised to a
muslim family in new york city so that's
why i don't have an arabic accent i did
not realize it back then but i was
extremely religious my partner is arab
and we are both highly educated in
physics engineering and islamic studies
until last year we were both religious
until we found out that the crown has
not only scientific but also moral
mistakes
for example the sun sets in a murky
water or that the earth is flat or that
salty and fresh okay all right all right
she didn't mess with a bunch of [ __ ]
research and stuff like that hang on no
time for all this stuff
people want to go through the [ __ ]
bible in the quran and start saying like
historically scientifically speaking i
really don't care for that stuff all
right well now for our next videos prime
hey man listen shout outs to her man in
terms of like apostate porn this is
probably the number one on my list i'll
definitely go check it out
but
you know
good lord
you are playing with fireballs yeah
don't don't don't and don't even think
of
traveling to your country
and think everything is going to be
kosher and safe i wouldn't feel well
it's not going to be coaster because
you're here
no i hope your family don't have that
because people don't know what you do
don't think you're going to go in your
country and think that everything is
going to be halal
god damn
oh my days like everything that's crazy
some people will be online just just
like
just like living in a [ __ ] crypt
neighborhood and be like hey bloods come
find me this is my address
that's what you're doing you are playing
with fire might be doing whoa whoa whoa
to me signing the issue that she does
only things and that she's an ex-muslim
i don't even care to me it's like you're
leaning on that to launch your brand yep
that's weird
but hey if you want to invite problems
into your life go ham grill this is
i don't get it
that's crazy